(man) The sharks are back
in an all-new season
of "Shark Tank,"
Where hopeful entrepreneurs
from across the country
dream of a chance
to secure an investment
and gain powerful partners
to start, grow, or save
their businesses.
Our project is a full-length
action film.
I'm out.
If the sharks hear
a great idea,
they're ready to invest
using their own money.
We're seeking $5 million.
My money's getting cold here.
And they'll fight each other
for a piece of the action.
Wait, you're out.
I can come back in.
Wait a minute,
wait a minute.
They're crazy!
But first, the entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll walk away
with nothing.
Now I'm gonna give you
24 seconds
to come high and come hard.
Sharks, enough talking.
(both) It's party time.
It's sink...
I'd rather follow
the green than the dream.
Or swim.
You say to Barbara,
"Listen, you witch."
(laughs)
"If you don't come in
on this deal,
I'm gonna set you on fire
with lighter fluid."
♪♪
Who are the sharks?
They're self-made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Barbara Corcoran
went from working
as a waitress in Manhattan
to building the city's
preeminent real estate empire.
Daymond John is a fashion mogul
and branding expert
who grew his homemade
clothing line
into the globally recognized
fashion brand Fubu.
Robert Herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
Who sold his first
internet companies
for over $350 million.
And Mark Cuban,
notorious billionaire
entrepreneur
and the outspoken owner
of the Dallas Mavericks.
♪♪
I'm Erica Cohen.
And I'm Lori Barbera,
and our company is...
(both) Baby's badass burgers.
Smokin',
O.B., no cheese.
Baby's badass burgers is
a mobile food truck concept
that has a gorgeous
pink truck,
beautiful burger babes,
and the best burgers in L.A.
Order up.
I have an extensive
background
in events and marketing.
And my background is
in the restaurant industry.
I've opened and launched
many restaurant concepts.
Whoo!
Together,
we're the perfect duo.
We really do have
the perfect Burger.
I agree.
It's not an easy thing to
make the perfect cheeseburger.
You have to have a great
bun-To-Meat ratio,
you have to have quality meat,
the perfect bun,
and quality ingredients.
We have all of those
with Baby's.
Great. Thank you.
Thank you. Enjoy.
(Erica) We're ready to
take Baby's to the next step.
We have a huge hit
on our hands,
and this is just
the beginning.
One taste of our burgers,
and we know
that the sharks
will be hooked.
♪♪
Hi, I'm Erica Cohen.
And I'm Lori Barbera,
and our company is...
(both) Baby's badass burgers.
And we're looking
for $250,000
for 30% of our business.
Baby's badass burgers
is a playfully unique
and entertaining
bright pink mobile food truck
that sells high-quality
gourmet burgers
served by a fun, friendly,
and attractive staff.
While opening a restaurant
in L.A.,
I met and became friends
with Lori,
who also shared my love
for the almighty burger.
We took our concept
to the streets of l.A.
In late 2009,
and have developed
a cult-like following
ever since.
Our motto is,
"Come for the burgers,
stay for the buns."
(laughter)
Today... (laughs)
Today we've brought some of
our signature burgers for you
so you can try these
beauties for yourselves.
For Robert, I have
an all-American girl,
and for Barbara, I have
a she's smokin'.
(Barbara) I like the way
it sounds.
We know you like
barbecue sauce.
Yeah, I do like
(woman) For Kevin, I have
an original beauty.
For Daymond, I have
the other woman.
Thank you.
(laughs) The other woman!
Yeah, this baby got back.
And for Mark,
I have the perfect 10.
Thank you.
Oh, please!
Stop sucking up!
(laughter)
Wow, this is the heaviest
Burger I've ever...
(Barbara) I know.
That's our half a pound
"Maneater."
That's a lot of meat,
ladies.
Yes, it is.
It is.
It's a great burger.
Thanks.
Thank you.
All we need
is an investor
to jump on board so that
soon you'll see
a baby's badass burgers
in every major city.
So, which one of you sharks is
going to take the biggest bite?
So I give you $250,000.
How do you spend that money?
That's going to, um,
our first storefront.
So you've been successful with
the trucks, and now you're
giving that up?
Very successful.
Great, wildly successful
with the truck...
interesting.
And now it's time
to turn this into
a brick-and-mortar business.
What makes you think that
the brick-and-mortar will work?
(Erica) Just simply because
the product is great.
People love it.
I mean, literally,
we open the doors, and we get
a line wherever we go.
Different business.
The minute you--
it is, but--
we know.
We--know. We--we really know.
You guys do realize $250,000
won't cover the front door?
It will not.
No, it'll--
we actually have some of our
own money to invest as well.
Yeah.
We put ourselves
in an excellent position
so that we are able
to also put $50,000.
Okay, that's still not
gonna get it done.
Still not gonna be enough, though.
It's not gonna come close.
Is that even enough
to open the first store?
Yes.
Absolutely.
We're looking at
a 1,500-Square-Foot-Joint.
Square foot.
So you're not considering
making more trucks?
Cor--are you?
We're not considering
the trucks.
(Barbara) why not?
We want to roll these out
as storefronts.
Why not? Why not?
Because trucks,
as--As fun as it is,
it really was always
the vision
to roll it out
brick-and-mortar.
And that's what we do.
That's where
our experience lies.
(Kevin) are you actually
profitable?
We sure are.
Yes.
In the three years that
we've been in business,
we've done $815,000.
(Daymond) Total?
Total.
Yes.
Average was $250,000 a year?
Well, we're looking to do
$375,000 by december.
Erica, what's your profit?
We take home about 15%,
as opposed to a 10%
which is usually standard
in the restaurant--
and that's after paying
yourself, everybody?
You've paid yourself as well?
We're included in that.
Okay.
But, Erica, you get this
once-in-a-lifetime chance...
Mm-hmm.
To get in front of us...
right.
To pitch an idea.
You come out
with a working concept,
and you say, "No, we're not
gonna do that.
We're gonna do this drawing,
which we've never done."
No, and we--we have that.
I mean, we--
(speaks indistinctly)
right.
Lori and both come from
the restaurant industry.
Exactly.
Between us, we've both
opened seven restaurants, so...
but how many of these
restaurants have you opened?
None yet.
We're coming with a concept,
a brand, and a product...
right.
And an experience
that we knew was--
We know is already proven.
That store is gonna cost
$750,000 to open it.
You won't know for three months
if you're gonna make it or not.
There's so many--
So much risk
that you don't have now
with your business model.
Operating a physical location
like that
costs hundreds
of thousands of dollars.
I don't get it. What's
the matter with you people?
Why aren't you sticking
to the trucks?
Why aren't you saying,
"Mr. Wonderful,
"Give me $250,000
to open up 5 more trucks.
In return, it's 20%."
Why isn't that the story?
Our--Our dream is to open
restaurants.
Yeah, but you're telling us--
You're telling us
you don't understand
the fundamental tenets
of business.
Yeah.
Number-one rule--
Follow the money.
And the money is right
in front of you.
It may be great
that you have a dream
to open up a restaurant...
Mm-hmm.
But I'd rather follow
the green than the dream.
And this doesn't mean you won't
open the restaurant.
Yes, it does.
I forbid you.
If they get to 20,
30 trucks...
I forbid you to ever
open that restaurant.
Why? Why would you
say that?
Because it's a really
bad idea.
You have a business
that's making money.
You've just proven
the concept.
Why have you decided to open
a brick-and-mortar operation
instead of replicating
this truck?
I think there's a cap-out
on the trucks.
It's a cash business. Um,
you have to be so hands-on.
You have to be present.
And... we really want--
there you go!
There you go!
Hands-On--
Ding, ding, ding, ding,
ding, ding, ding!
No, I'm on that truck
every single day.
I work my ass off.
You understand that when you
own a restaurant...
Erica, so what?
You're putting in 80 hours
a week
in the restaurant, too.
Absolutely.
I've worked in restaurants,
I've lived in them,
I've opened them,
I've put my money in them.
It takes ten times more money
to open one restaurant
than set up one more truck.
You're right.
You could have ten times
the leverage,
ten times the sales,
with the same amount of money.
I understand your point
to expand on the trucks.
It was our vision to really
go for it
and do the brick-and-mortars.
None of your data
works in a brick-and-mortar.
It is a completely
different business.
Good pitch on the truck.
Bad pitch on
the brick-and-mortar. I'm out.
I kind of get why finally--
why you want to open
a restaurant.
I think you're looking for
a home for your business.
You just want to settle in
Somewhere.
Um, what disturbs me--
You love to invest
in a business where someone's
in love with their business,
instead of the guy who's trying
to get out of that business
and get into the new business.
The idea that you're
escaping
what you're doing now
and don't want it anymore
makes me want
to escape it, too,
so I'm out.
The truck
isn't going anywhere.
I mean, we'll always
have the truck.
It's absolutely not going anywhere.
The truck will help
the restaurant,
and the restaurant
will help the truck.
Right.
Although I love seeing
a truck, and you're right,
maybe it would be great
to see ten Baby's trucks,
I see bigger than that.
That's always been
the bigger picture with us.
Guys, I-I see the--the value.
I also see the constraints
on the truck.
But it's a very
binary decision.
Either it takes off
and explodes,
or it craters
very, very quickly
Like any number of--of people
who had a lot of vision,
a lot of hope,
and a lot of great burgers.
Also, I know $350,000
is not gonna get it done.
I don't think you really
put the numbers on paper enough
to really dig in to see
what it's going to take,
and for that reason,
I'm out.
I'm gonna give you a 9
out of 10 on the Burger.
I'm a burger connoisseur.
We love that. Thank you.
I've eaten them from
all around the world.
There's nothing wrong
with the product.
But I'm gonna give you
a 1 out of 10 on your strategy.
You charbroiled a great idea.
You killed it.
I mean, you have
a fantastic business.
But I think you came in here
and got slaughtered
by trying to push us
in a direction
that you hadn't proven.
Had you said you could do
ten trucks
and you wanted $500,000,
that might've been interesting.
Um...
I think you made
a classic mistake in here
in the shark tank today.
I'm out.
I've been listening
very closely.
What I was listening for
was that at any given time
as we were speaking,
as partners,
you would have said,
"You know what?
"Maybe we are being
too aggressive,
"and we're ready
to rethink that concept
and roll out the trucks
and make some money."
but you're too stuck
on what you wanna do.
And I was ready to give you
the money.
Too late. I'm out.
Okay.
Okay. Well, thank you.
Thank you for your time.
Good luck, guys.
Thanks for the Burger.
Thank you.
Burgers are great, guys.
♪♪
Good, now we can eat
the Burger,
relax a bit, you know?
I finished mine already.
Yeah. Wow.
She was absolutely set
on having a store.
Definitely.
It was a dream.
She almost had a chip
on her shoulder about it.
(Daymond) Yeah.
And nothing we said was
gonna get her away from it.
I think the sharks
underestimated,
um, our experience,
how much we know,
and our ability to open
and launch a restaurant.
It's gonna be their loss.
♪♪
Next up is James Lavitola
and Brian Pitt
with a unique investment
opportunity for the Sharks.
Hi. I'm James Lavitola.
And I'm Brian Pitt,
and our project
is titled "Track days."
We're seeking $5 million...
(Robert) Whoa!
(Daymond) That's
a lot of money.
In exchange for 34% equity
in our production.
Now, "Track days" is
a full-length action film.
I'm out.
It revolves around
the exciting world of...
I'm out.
A motorcycle
world championship.
I'm out.
(laughs)
You're so open-minded,
Mark.
I'm out. Did I say I was out?
Again, "Track days" is
a full-length action film
that revolves around
the exciting world
of a motorcycle
world championship.
And what better way
to make a blockbuster
than by combining
one of the largest-Grossing
movie genres
with the second-Most-Watched
sport in the entire world?
Which is?
Professional motorcycle racing.
Now, we went ahead
and put together
a little teaser trailer
for you sharks.
(Robert) Awesome.
But no premiere
would be complete
without some
Good old-fashioned
American popcorn
and candy.
Carrie, our lovely
umbrella girl,
is gonna pass you out
some treats.
Thank you, Carrie.
Now James will be dropping
you off some premiere gift bags
'cause we all want a little
good swag
when we go
to a movie premiere.
Let's start your engines,
'cause the race
is about to begin.
(Robert) Vroom!
(rumbling)
(motorcycle engine roaring)
(engine revving)
(beeping)
(revving continues)
(tires screech)
(hard rock music playing)
(thudding and crash)
(tires screeching)
(crashing and whirring,
motorcycles roaring)
(crashing)
(tires screech)
(thud)
♪♪
(motorcycle roars)
That's it?
(laughing)
So, boys, you want 5 million
bucks to make a movie?
I know how you feel
that, you know,
you think that filmmaking
is a crap shoot,
which we completely
understand.
However, Brian is considered
somewhat an expert
in this field.
(laughs)
And with the crap shoot
statement,
we're gonna make it
so that you're the house,
and the house always wins.
(mouth full) How are you
gonna do that?
Brian?
Happy to explain it
to you.
We're gonna be bringing you
a packaged product
that has, uh...
efficient foreign sales,
Efficient, uh,
distribution.
Efficient or sufficient?
Sufficient.
Essentially, what we'll
be doing is we'll be
putting a-a script
together,
which is in the process
of being rewritten.
You don't even have
a script yet?
We--
we have the story.
We have the story.
We specifically decided
to go a different
route with this--
me and my buddies get pitched
stuff all the time.
Absolutely.
And we invest sometimes
in movies,
But nobody ever comes Along
and says,
"Give me money
and then we'll do the work."
They pitch the script.
We say...
absolutely.
"We like it,"
"We don't like it."
"Who's the producer?"
that is
the traditional thinking.
We're gonna educate you...
correct.
On the new way that films
are financed,
to where you guys aren't
risking your money.
(Barbara) So we don't
put in money?
We don't want you to risk
your money.
Often, what happens is,
people go out
and they put a script together
and they get an actor,
and then they come to a company
like the one I used to run,
where we would finance
films.
Do you have an actor?
No. By design
we don't have an actor.
Specifically don't have
an actor attached.
Okay, so I know mark is--
I know mark is already out--
We're getting him back in.
He's coming back.
I've heard this story
many times before.
Yes.
Um, I executive-produced
"The Crow."
Yes, we know that.
(Kevin) You make any money?
It became a horror flick in
regards to making my money back.
(laughter)
So... I'm out.
(Robert) This is a record.
Now--
This is the fastest two guys
have ever dropped out.
We're gonna get them back in.
We're gonna get you back.
We are gonna put together
a package
that you won't spend one dime
until we show you
foreign sales,
domestic sales,
distribution deals,
product placement.
You know, the film business
is a bit of a chicken
before the egg.
You can make it happen
if you have the money.
if you have
the best script in the world.
You can make it happen
if you have
the best actor in the world.
You know,
and you can make it happen
if you're the right people.
Why would we have
confidence in you
and give you $5 million?
What's your background?
So, film-wise, I've been
in the business
for about 12 years or so.
I've been head of production--
Head of physical production
for a--for a very
successful indie company.
We secured a 9-picture
distro deal
with a major studio.
We've produced eight feature
films that went theatrical.
And...
how many--How many did you
make money on?
We grossed well over
$200 million.
"Mr. Brooks" is one
that did fairly well.
It was Kevin Costner,
Demi Moore, uh, Dane Cook.
Did a movie
called "Waiting..."
that did
very, very, very well.
And what about you, James?
What about you?
What's your background here?
Uh, when I was younger,
I was on Broadway.
I came to L.A., did stunts.
You know, I'm a huge
motorcycle fan.
And there's been such a lack
of movies made about them.
(Robert) I have an issue
with the subject matter.
Yes, sir?
I love racing, but not many
people in North America
Love motorcycle racing.
Correct.
Absolutely.
Americans love nascar,
not this kind of racing.
Correct.
When we attach an actor,
that will sell to America.
If I put, uh, Ryan Gosling
in this,
my girlfriend's gonna go see it
because of Ryan Gosling.
But earlier you said that
the actor's not important.
No, uh...
now you're saying he is.
I'm gonna jump in here
for a second.
The actor's not attached
by design.
We're too early
in the stages.
If I put an actor
to it at this point,
when we got down the road,
it may not warrant
the sales that I need.
Walk me through
the numbers a little bit.
I give you $5 million today.
You don't have a script.
You don't have an actor.
(James) We have a story.
What happens to my cash--
What we wanna do
is take your money,
put it into let's say
an escrow account
or some kind of interest-bearing
account
to where we can't touch it.
At that time, we can go and put
the package together for you.
We'll have a list of ten actors
that fit the leading roles--
So can't start the project
until people know...
until you approve of everything.
That the cash is there?
We will not start the project
until you're happy
with the calculated risk
that you would have to take.
Because it would be
very minimal.
Otherwise, we don't do
the movie.
Guys, let--Let me try
to help you out.
When you take a movie,
and you have money behind it,
then all the people you're
pitching to think you're real.
You're using our money
as bait, basically?
Correct.
Yes, absolutely.
Absolutely.
Yeah. Absolutely.
The movie business--
It's the worst business
I've ever seen in my life.
But it can also be a very
lucrative business.
I can't give you a dime
until I see the script,
I know who's att--Like, I just
can't get my mind around that.
Brian, I think you're
doing this 'cause you can't--
'cause you're stuck
And you can't get the money
any other way.
Oh, no...
why? Why should I take
the risk today?
(James) Here's the other thing
that we're all forgetting about.
This has such a massive,
built-In audience that--
You have nothing today!
Who's still left
on the executive producer List?
Uh, we're not--We're out--
We're already out, guys.
We're already out.
Definitely?
(Daymond) We're out.
All right.
All right, you know,
take it down.
(Mark) Take 'em off.
(Robert) Oh, that's funny.
Ohh... (laughing)
(Daymond) oh!
Oh...
well, I see Mr. Wonderful's
next on the list,
so let--Let him speak.
Yes, sir.
Please do.
It is a horrifically bad idea.
I forbid you to proceed.
I'm out.
Okay.
Mr. Wonderful's next.
(Robert) No!
(James) He's going...
(Barbara laughs)
(James)
We got Barbara and rob.
(Barbara) It's a--I'm next,
I'm next.
But I can't picture myself
going home
and Telling my teenage son who
I won't let get a motorcycle,
"I'm financing a film
on motorcycle racing."
Scare the crap out of me.
It's not my kind of thing.
I'm out.
Okay.
Vanna?
(Daymond and mark laughing)
"Vanna."
(Barbara) Take me down.
Take me on down.
Okay, hold on
because now
this has become an issue.
And...
(Robert) What's going on?
It's going down to you,
Robert.
(laughter)
(Brian) There's
a producer left.
(laughter continues)
You gotta give an "a"
for showmanship, right?
That's great.
You know, Robert--
and we anticipated this.
We anticipated this,
so we figured you'd want
to be in the race as well.
You'll be in the movie, so...
(sharks) Ohh!
(Barbara) Gotta say yes.
I know you wanna be
on the track, in the movie,
on the bike.
Look...
ludicrous concept.
You're transferring the risk
completely from you
to me.
I can't get there
without knowing more
about it.
Okay.
Okay. We can do that.
(Robert) I love racing.
Yeah.
"We'll switch our plan
just like that."
I can't be involved
on nothing.
Okay.
I have--look, I have...
so... I'm out.
Okay.
Hit it, Vanna.
Okay, get rid of him.
(Robert) No! No!
There--He's out, Vanna!
(sharks) Ohh...
good luck, guys.
Close the cap.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you very much.
Good luck, guys.
We appreciate it.
Thank you.
♪♪
You know, I saw this
exact same deal
in an e-mail from Nigeria.
(sharks laugh)
Next into the tank
is Mary Beth Lugo,
with a better way
to teach kids
something
they all want to learn.
Whoa.
♪♪
Hi. My name is Mary Beth Lugo,
and this is my product,
Kazam.
I am here today seeking
$300,000
in exchange for 20% equity
in my business.
Kazam is a balance bike
that is revolutionizing
the way kids learn
how to ride.
If you notice, this bike
does not have pedals,
and here's why.
The key to learning
how to ride a bike
is developing balance.
Think of it
as a building process.
You take one step at a time.
With Kazam, children are
able to learn by themselves
at their own pace,
which makes it easy
for them to then transition
onto a regular bicycle.
With the help of Kazam,
kids are having fun,
while at the same time
learning a life skill
that will stay with them
forever.
Now, who's ready to ride
the revolution with me?
Beth, I think you should
send the kiddies off,
because I have a bunch
of questions
they probably
don't wanna hear.
Can you ride off, honey?
(Robert) Oh, what a diva.
She doesn't want to leave.
(laughs) So cute.
What are you making them for
and what are you
selling them for?
We make them for $28.25.
The wholesale price
is $45.
Direct to consumer
for $99.95.
Mary Beth, my option,
if I'm struggling
in this economy,
is I can buy training wheels
for $19,
or I can buy a Kazam.
Both outcomes
are gonna be the same.
Children have been learning
how to ride a bicycle
for decades
with training wheels.
It's that it's improving
the way they're
learning to ride.
(Barbara) How did you
come up with the idea?
Born out of need, or...
actually, this concept
has been popular
in Europe for some time.
We had a European neighbor
who introduced us
to this idea.
We tried it with my own child
who was then 2 at the time,
and he learned like that.
(snaps fingers)
Wow.
Me made our own design.
We have a patented frame design.
(Barbara) What age category
would be on this bike?
Maybe 2 1/2
up to 5, 5 1/2.
It kind of depends on--
but I'm curious to why
this company
already has been doing this
in Europe,
and then they're not
selling over here
if it was a-a product
in demand.
Actually, we are not
the only ones now
in the market
in the United States.
Okay.
But what's different
about ours
is the patented
frame design
with the foot rest area.
And...
tell us about your competition.
How much are they selling?
The market's actually
fragmented right now
with several small companies
like ourselves.
How many?
Five or six, probably.
What are your sales,
Mary Beth?
Tell us about your sales.
You know, what are they...
to date--
We haven't been in business
quite three years.
We have $1.4 million.
Whoa. What's your sales
in the last year
and the year before?
Last year
were $611,000.
In 2010, they were
$384,000.
Great growth.
(Kevin) What do you think
you'll sell next year?
Next year we're projecting
$1.5 million.
On the million dollars,
what will your profit be?
The profit margin is
about 36% to 37%.
I have a problem
with your margins.
They're not enough.
How do you get them up
to 45%, 47%?
Well, right now we're
in a situation where
we're doing batch
manufacturing, which means
a small quantity
that we're ordering--
1,680 bikes...
do you know how many you'd
have to buy at a time
to increase your margins
by 20%?
You gotta get them up
to close to 50%.
We realistically would have
to get to about 50,000.
50--so you've got a ways
to go then.
Fantastic growth.
If it maintains this way,
you're gonna suck up
a lot of cash.
Mm-hmm.
The only way to get
some relief from that
is to enhance these
margins dramatically.
Okay, Mary Beth.
I think what's going to
happen here is
you're going to require
a significant amount of capital.
And that's what I don't like
about your deal.
Because, for me, it's
how do I get my money back?
I'm not gonna take
that chance.
I'm out.
Okay.
And let me just say this--
This is not limited
to toy and bicycle.
This bridges to education,
preschools,
daycares,
occupational therapy.
Have you gone back
to the european market,
or are all of your sales
in north America?
Actually, we just got
picked up by
the largest sporting goods
store in all of Europe.
It has 700 stores.
And they just ordered
a container F.O.B.
Okay, so you're talking about
raising $300,000.
What else would you use
the money for?
We'd actually like to create
an--another product.
We want to have
the 2-Wheeled bike
as the next step up
from the Kazam,
for the "Kazam Graduate."
(Robert) A pedal bike?
A pedaled bike.
Why would you do that?
Do you know how competitive
that is?
(laughs)
That is.
You can buy a bike
for $39.
That's true, but with
a quality product
and the fact that we've
created a loyal customer--
I forbid you to do that.
And I'm out.
Mary Beth, it sounds like you're
becoming the market leader.
It scares me that you would
want to go away
from something that you're
great at, you're growing,
and then start competing with
a huge market
with huge competitors.
Why would you do that?
Well, and I'll tell you why--
Because we get asked
all the time
from our retailers,
"When are you coming out
with something new?"
we want to build
a brand--
Yeah, you're, you know,
you're gonna drown
in opportunity.
Entrepreneurs make
that mistake every day.
Just because somebody asks
doesn't mean you should do.
I commend you on the sales.
You made a great argument.
I mean, you've answered
all the questions really well.
It's just a personal thing.
I wouldn't buy one.
I'm not saying
that's good or bad.
You gotta have somebody along
for the journey
who really believes in it.
Um... I'm not that guy.
I'm out.
(Daymond) Uh, I think you have
a great concept here,
but if I gave you my money,
I would feel like
I would never get it back.
I'm out.
Mm. Okay.
What I'm concerned about
is I don't see your competition
as being only
the tricycle market.
It's the tricycle market,
the training wheel market.
It takes a lot of money
and Real high focus.
I'm wondering--
You have a very mild manner.
Are you the type of person
that could do that?
Really? I'm surprised
you said that. (laughs)
I just don't feel
that fire in you.
Listen, I'm the one
that's running
the day-to-day operations.
I could picture you
as organized, but again,
even in that answer, I don't
feel that fire coming out.
Are you willing to pour boiling
oil over your competitors?
(laughter)
(Mark) Yeah.
That's what she's asking you.
In a nice way.
Are you saying
she's not aggressive?
I'm not sure.
I'm here because
I want to blast them away.
I want to emerge this company
as the Leader in this market.
Barbara's right.
When you get a chance
to step on the throat
of your competitor,
you just gotta step, squish...
gosh.
And let the roadkill be
picked up by somebody else.
You give articulate answers,
nice and steady as you go,
but I'm looking
for that thing, that heat!
You're right. I'm a shy person.
I'm a reserved person.
But I have spent
every day
of the last three years
working on this
because I know
it's a proven concept.
I know that we can be
the Leader.
And I want to be
that person
who is poised and ready
to enter the mass market
when that time comes.
You know what? I'm gonna--
I'm gonna find out just how much
killer you have in you.
I'm gonna make you an offer.
$300,000
for 40%...
(Kevin) Ouch!
Okay?
(Daymond) Ooh.
But it's contingent
on you convincing Barbara
to come in with me.
Three sharks are out.
Mark has made
Mary Beth an offer,
but she must convince
a skeptical Barbara
to go in on the deal.
$300,000 for 40%...
(Kevin) Ouch!
Okay?
(Daymond) Ooh.
But it's contingent
on you convincing Barbara
to come in with me.
So she does not get
Barbara to come aboard...
I'm out.
And I'm gonna give you
24 seconds to convince Barbara,
so you're going to have to
come high and Come hard,
and we'll find out just
how aggressive you are.
(Daymond) Let's go.
Mary Beth, I'm gonna
give it to you right now.
You say to Barbara,
"Listen, you witch."
(laughter)
"If you don't come in
on this deal,
I'm gonna set you on fire
with Lighter fluid."
Set her 24-Second clock,
please.
There he goes.
Are you ready?
Go.
I've had to learn
this business
from the ground up.
I did not have any prior
business experience.
Nobody knows this company
more than I do.
I get up early, I work while
my kids are at school,
I take them to soccer,
I come home,
and I work until 11:00 at night
every single day.
This has become my life.
And I am not willing
to walk away from it
until we become
the top leader.
I'm sold. Mark, I'm in.
Do we have a deal?
(exhales)
(Kevin) 40%.
40% is high!
It'll be worth it.
40% is too high.
We valued our company
correctly,
and I'm definitely
confident in that.
Then come back and make
a counteroffer.
Could we do 32%?
♪♪
Okay, okay, okay.
$300,000 for 32%,
Barbara and I partnering
together,
and we come in and we make
Kazam huge.
Do we have a deal?
We have a deal.
Amen.
(Daymond) All right.
(Barbara) Nice.
(clapping)
I'm proud of you.
(laughs)
Thank you.
A big hug.
Awesome. Thank you.
You got better
as you went.
Exactly.
Barbara, you hurt
my feelings.
I love you!
I wanted to hurt
your feelings!
I wanted
to hurt your feelings!
Thank you.
I need to take one of these
home for jakers.
Jake's gonna love it.
I never thought insulting
people was the way to go,
but you brought something
out of her.
That's--She's a snake.
Who?
Barbara.
(laughter)
I can't believe this.
It's a dream come true.
It's what I've been
working for for so long--
for the last three years.
This is going to be
the big break.
♪♪
Earlier this season,
Cheryl Rigdon
failed to get a deal
with the sharks
for her makeup tool,
the Spatty.
I think we're all in love
with you.
It's just too early for us.
Let's see what she's
up to now.
♪♪
Even though I didn't
get a deal,
I haven't given up
on the Spatty or Spatty Daddy.
Oh, you saw us
on "Shark Tank"?
before "Shark Tank," I only
sold 15 Spattys.
After "Shark Tank,"
through my web site,
I've received pre-orders
for 7,000 Spattys.
At one point, I had to stop
taking orders for the Spatty
because I was completely
sold out.
Sales from my product
have reached $32,000.
You know, it might not seem like
a lot, but that's huge to me.
Well, I can't wait
to see it.
And with that money,
I've been able
to take my handmade
prototype
into a mass-produced product
at a real factory.
There you go. Is that what
you were looking for?
Yes! That is awesome!
I'm really proud to say
that I'm building this company
on my own.
When the sharks said
they didn't have time
to build a company
from the ground up,
I didn't understand that then,
but I understand it now.
(laughs)
It was great talking
to you, too, Daymond.
Thank you.
In the tank, Daymond offered
to help commit me to people
in the beauty industry.
Not only has he done that,
but he's worked with me
to help me find
a licensing deal.
"Shark Tank" was definitely
the catalyst
to get my business
off the ground.
Company's doing great,
and, you know, the future's
looking really bright
for the Spatty and Spatty Daddy.
♪♪
Next up are Lance Yabut
and Tom Kanemoto
with a way to make every party
more memorable.
Hi, my name's Lance Yabut.
And my name is Tom Kanemoto.
We're seeking $300,000
in exchange for 10% equity
in pink shutter photobooths.
We've taken the fun
and nostalgia
of the old-fashioned
photo Booth
and turned everything
on its head.
We're revolutionizing
the entire industry.
Have you guys ever tried
to take a family picture,
to only have them come out
stiff and boring?
With a super-fun
pink shutter photobooth...
(Robert chuckles)
You won't even have to beg
your kids to smile.
Our pink shutter
photobooths
are some of the most premium,
high quality,
and luxurious photo booths
in the nation.
Unlike other cramped
photo booths,
our spacious booth
means more people,
more poses, and more fun.
You can just imagine
how interesting
those pictures get
as the night wears on.
Only you won't have to
imagine it,
because not only do your guests
get a high-Quality
printout to take home,
but you get a copy
of all the pictures.
Whoo-Hoo! Memories
to last a lifetime.
(laughing)
So, sharks, enough talking.
Let's get ready
to have some fun.
Come on down, pick a prop.
(both) It's party time!
Hey! Why not?
Whoo!
Let's go. Come on down.
Come on down, guys.
So, uh, we got a nice--
a lot of cool props for you
guys to choose from.
So go ahead,
put your props on...
Oh, I love that.
Whenever you pick them out.
We knew that was for you.
You guys are--
It's definitely for me.
Oh, there you go.
Daymond, I feel like
this one is for you.
You got me, like...
(laughter)
Oh, yeah, baby.
Money.
Oh, yeah. Yeah.
Get in here.
Look at this guy.
Wow.
You gotta hold this.
(laughter)
(Robert) hang on.
Get in here, mark.
Get Cuban in here.
Let's squeeze it in.
Get in here.
All right, hit it.
(man) Nice.
(Daymond) Cheese!
(shutter clicks)
(indistinct conversations
and laughter)
(Barbara) That's fun!
(Lance) Yeah, it was fun,
right?
It's fun!
Did you have fun?
But we weren't paying
anything.
Okay, boys, let's walk us
through the business model here.
Our business model
is a corporate model.
We own and distribute
all of our photo booths
across many different
locations.
Currently, we're open
in Sacramento, Los Angeles...
thank you.
And Las Vegas,
San Francisco...
Look at Daymond.
And San Diego.
(laughter)
So do you own
all the equipment?
Yes.
That stays on your
balance sheet?
That's correct.
We own all the assets in
the company, free and clear.
How big, money-wise,
is this business today?
Well, in our first
fiscal year,
we pulled in about
$195,000.
In our second fiscal year,
we're in our first quarter,
and we've pulled in
$135,000 already.
Guys, look. Photo booths
are ancient.
What makes you guys
different?
Well, what makes us different
is that we've cut
the overhead costs
from most photo booths.
Most photo booth companies
can only service events
if they're making
$1,000 per event,
because it's a huge setup.
So how much does each
setup cost you, all in?
It costs us about $3,500
in equipment
and about $500 labor
to actually build the booth.
(Robert) How are people
finding it?
As you go to a new market,
how do I know you're there?
Well, we have strategic
partnerships already set up
with the largest deal sites
on the internet--
Living Social and Groupon.
So, are there any competitors
that are doing
the same thing you're doing?
There are--There are a few
competitors out there.
We're not gonna lie.
There's a lot of competition.
So what is--Okay, so what's
your secret sauce,
or why are people coming
to you?
Well, one of the big things
that makes us different
is most photo booth companies
that are out there
are mom-and-pop shops
that are more than happy
to just be contained
in that one area.
Lance, do you think
for $3 million
I could find a couple of guys
with pink shirts and black ties,
buy some photo equipment,
advertise in a few cities,
and crush you
like cockroaches?
I don't--
'cause that's the question
you have to answer.
That's the thing
that matters to me.
Now we're talking
real money.
This is not worth $3 million.
You know why?
There's nothing that's
proprietary about it. Nothing.
$3 million's a joke.
I'm out.
But we're making money.
Last 30 days of sales--
$83,000.
This fiscal year, we're slated
to make $500,000
with no capital infusion.
And what will your profit
be on that?
60%.
Why do you need the money?
We don't need the money.
We have great credit.
We have--We have banks
that... (speaks indistinctly)
I'll be your partner
for no money. No problem.
We need the strategic
introductions.
You guys paid yourself yet?
Um, I currently do
take a salary.
What do you take?
I'm taking $99,000.
I know these don't
sound like a lot, but...
oh! Wait a minute.
And the company made
$300,000, correct?
$333,000.
So you took 30%
out of the company already?
No, not yet. No, I just
started taking a salary
just two, three months ago.
Okay, so you're gonna
pay yourself $100,000.
What are you gonna pay
yourself?
I haven't really
thought about it yet.
No, no, no. Come on.
Don't play possum with me.
He's getting $100,000.
Okay.
What are you gonna
pay yourself?
Same.
So $200,000.
$200,000 in salaries
already, right?
There's nothing wrong
with that.
Wait a minute, wait a minute.
$200,000 in salaries, and you
just took $300,000 from us.
Okay. Can you generate
$200,000 in sales?
I believe so.
Okay. You just
made your money back.
Yeah.
No, that's not right.
Guys, here--Here's
the challenge.
All you've done is shown
everybody
that there's a unique
market out there,
and while they may not be
as good as you,
you've set the price
for your service,
and the fact that there's
huge margins
for someone to come in
and undercut you.
For that reason,
I'm out.
You don't need the money,
but yet you want $300,000.
You're gonna pay each other
$100,000 apiece.
Only offering us 10%.
Wanting us to go out
and work for you.
$300,000 is a lot of money.
That is a lot of money...
(speaks indistinctly)
Right?
I'm out.
Thank you.
(Robert) Lance,
you're a great hustler.
I mean, you guys are out there,
you're doing it.
You're not the reason
I can't be in.
My time is the reason.
You know--
We just need
a half an hour a week.
That's all we're asking
of your time.
I-I gotta be out.
Well, thank you.
Anybody else here?
You're the only one
left, Barbara.
You're it, Barbara.
I believe everything
you're saying.
I think you got
a good thing going here.
I think you're... you're
like an eveready battery.
I think your valuation
is way high.
I think you know that
already.
So I'm gonna offer you
$300,000
for 33% of the business,
all right?
Okay.
The only thing I want is
when you pull your $100,000,
he pulls his $100,000,
as you take it,
I want to pull my $100,000,
too.
(Robert) Oh! Interesting.
Okay.
Barb, you sly fox.
I like the way you framed that.
Okay, look, you guys--
before you guys consider that,
if that's in the ballpark,
okay...
we're open to suggestions.
All right--
My money's getting cold here,
what do you say?
But wait.
Before you say yes...
hang on.
Wait, you're out, mark.
No, I-I can come back in.
No, you're not.
There's no law that says
I can't come back in.
What do you say, guys?
♪♪
Four sharks are out.
Lance and Tom have one offer
on the table from Barbara,
and Mark may have had
a change of heart.
My money's getting cold here,
what do you say?
But wait.
Before you say yes...
hang on.
Wait, you're out, mark.
No, I-I can come back in.
No, you're not.
There's no law that says
I can't come back in.
What do you say, guys?
At that valuation,
I'm far more interested.
I don't care
about necessarily
getting my money out
immediately.
I care about the growth.
What I would do is
do a deal comparable
to Barbara--
$300k for a third--
But wouldn't take
anything back
until your sales hit
a million dollars, so...
that's only one year.
Yeah, one year.
Well, it's one year or two year,
but at least you get there.
I can get you to
the event organizers.
I have a company called
axs tv
that broadcasts
live concerts,
and we're partners
with Aeg,
setting them up
at festivals.
Branding it as axs tv,
and having it there,
the challenge
is going to be
we'd have to move
incredibly fast,
simply because I think
competition is a huge risk.
So I'll let you pick.
W-Well, um,
so you said
you're gonna bring us
into the concert industry.
Right.
And then, Barbara, what will you
be bringing to the table?
I'm gonna bring to the table
exactly what I do
for every one of my successful
entrepreneurs.
I'm gonna bring
my marketing expertise.
I'm gonna bring everything
I know about business.
Okay.
I'm gonna be there
when you need it.
You're just going to get
a real working partner,
and, believe me,
there is a difference.
'cause if you were to speak
to all of my entrepreneurs,
that is what
makes the difference
between where they are
and where they went.
Can we have a minute
to--to talk it over?
Sure.
Okay. Thanks.
That was a creepy thing to do.
Absolutely.
What'd you do that for?
Because once it became a good
deal, it was a good deal.
At $3 million,
it wasn't a good deal.
Yeah, but you rode
on my good deal. Come on.
I mean, I like
both of their offers.
You know?
I mean, she's...
$100,000!
That's a lot of money.
You should know better.
You should know that I'm
the better partner,
and you know it, mark.
Actually, you set it up,
Barbara, I'll give you credit,
but they're crazy--
You'll give me credit?
They're crazy to pay you
a $100,000 salary.
They're crazy!
♪♪
All right, so we actually
have a proposal for you guys.
Would you, Barbara and Mark,
be willing to come in together?
Do we get to take the salary,
or which deal is it?
Without the salary. With--
Without the salary.
Oh...
so our counteroffer
is $300,000,
25% equity,
with Barbara and Mark.
I want to give you
a piece of advice right here.
We all noticed that you were
about to say yes
to Barbara's deal.
Kevin calls this
the "Bone in the mouth" theory.
(laughs) Yeah!
Now you're coming back
and you're changing it,
and I'm telling you--
but--But Mark came in,
and we feel that, like,
both of you guys are so good.
Okay, so what is your fi--
Your final offer is
you offering a counter--
That's not our final offer.
That's our counteroffer.
Your counteroffer is 25%...
25%.
For $300,000, split between
Barbara and Mark,
and no salary.
No salary.
Okay.
(Barbara) Here's the thing.
What I take exception to
is the deal got worse.
We had a 33% deal
on the table,
and you came back
and offered 25%.
We were gonna--Okay--
Okay, that's a no.
What do you say, Mark,
on the percentage?
Oh, absolutely not.
Okay, so you have two nos
on the 25%.
Guys, I'll make it easy.
Part of the drill
in going through this
is you guys presenting your
decision-Making process.
Right? You--
You weren't definitive,
and I don't want to be
in a scenario
where it's wishy-Washy
and we're not sure, we like it,
but we're not quite there.
I'm out.
What just happened?
(Kevin) You know,
two lab rats left
the shark tank...
(Barbara laughs)
They came back in.
They got slaughtered.
I hate it when that happens.
♪♪
What are you going to do?
All right, Barbara,
we accept your offer.
Good deal.
(laughter)
'cause you're
the only one left!
You're the only one left!
All right, baby.
(Kevin) Ahh.
All right, Barbara.
Good deal.
I really believe that you
will put in the time.
Yes, I really will.
Thank you.
Oh, you're just
sucking up now, Lance.
Thank you very much.
All right, thanks, guys.
Thanks for--
thanks for all--
Congratulations, guys.
All your help
and everything.
Good luck. Congratulations.
Barbara,
that was really clever.
Thank you.
You're getting--You're getting
the same salary they are.
Hey, I deserve it.
We're so happy we're
working with Barbara.
She said she's gonna
put the time in.
This partnership
with Barbara,
it's gonna take us
to a whole 'nother level
we've never been able
to reach before.